The variety of sushi served with raw sea food
has given rise to the notion that sushi is
any dish served with raw fish.
In fact though, sushi is more often than not
served in the western world with fully cooked
sea food, including: cooked imitation crab
(California roll); smoked salmon (Seattle
roll); grilled squid or octopus; fully cooked
shrimp; and fully cooked clam.
It is also often served with fried and battered
sea food of varying types.
There are also a variety of vegetarian sushi
dishes, including the very popular maki (cucumber
rolls).
Perhaps the reason sushi is so strongly thought
of as “raw fish” in the western world
is that, whatever the toppings, it is commonly
served cold.
Also, the general idea of raw fish isn’t
exactly to the liking of most westerners conceptually,
so that form of sushi stood out more when
it was first introduced; giving rise to the
notion that sushi was any dish that included
raw fish.
The term sushi, literally means “it’s
sour”, and comes from an ancient grammatical
form that is no longer used in other contexts.
The “sour” description comes from the
ancient way of preparing sushi by fermentation
of meat, generally sea food, packed in rice
with salt used as a preservative.
The vinegar produced from the fermenting rice
ends up breaking down the fish meat into amino
acids.
This, in turn, results in a strong umami flavor,
which is one of the five basic tastes the
human tongue can detect.
Once the meat was properly fermented, thus
preserved, the rice would then be discarded
and only the meat itself would be eaten.
Basically, it was just a handy way to preserve
meat before ice boxes and refrigerators.
Modern forms of sushi are not typically prepared
in this way and the rice is now the main part
of the meal.
Around the Muromachi period (1336-1573 AD),
they began adding vinegar, which aided in
preserving the food and in improving the flavor.
Eventually, this lead to the fermentation
process being shortened and ultimately abandoned
in favor of just eating it right away with
the rice.
A few centuries later, osaka and sushi combined
to form oshi-zushi.
In this type of sushi, various types of sea
food and rice are pressed using molds.
This eventually led to the version of sushi
created by Hanaya Yohei, in the 19th century,
which most of the world thinks of as “sushi”
today.
In this form, the sushi can be prepared extremely
quickly and eaten with one hand, making it
one of the earliest forms of fast food.